we flew to spain to test the third
generation of the cia leon sc in its
home country we wanted to see if this
version lives up to the sporty image its
makers are promoting
we'll be checking its performance in
everyday city driving as well as the
space it offers passengers and luggage
between the smooth roof and the smart
rear end
test driver reinhold eisenhofer points
out that the previous seat leon had five
doors now there's a three-door version
the sc stands for sport coupe
seat is hoping it will appeal to a new
market segment younger more dynamic
drivers
seat offers a range of nine engines for
the sc five gasoline powered and four
diesels
we tried out the 110 kilowatt two-liter
diesel with a 6-speed double clutch
transmission and an automatic start stop
mechanism
it accelerates from 0 to 108.4 seconds
reaching a maximum speed of 211
kilometers per hour
says the leon sc is a sporty but
comfortable chassis it feels dynamic and
light-footed that might be because it's
the lightest car in its class weighing
in at only 1100 kilos
he says compared to the five-door
version the sc has a slimmer a-pillar
that gives the driver somewhat better
visibility straight ahead and a smaller
blind spot
the side view shows the leon sc sporty
profile in particular the designers
noticeably sharpen the front and widen
the grill the lines and the details air
scoops and headlights are in the classic
trapeze form
even the side mirrors with their
integrated turn signals are like little
works of art
the most noticeable difference is that
it's now a three door instead of a five
door
it's also a bit shorter wider and
somewhat lower
and from behind that makes it look much
more like a sports sedan and not as much
like the usual compact car
harmonizing with the gently sloped rear
is a somewhat more lower
windshield from the side sharp lines all
around dynamically connect the rear with
the front
the sc's wheelbase is shorter by some
three and a half centimeters
that brings up the question of the space
offered by the interior
with two doors missing the first task is
to enter the vehicle but once we're in
we hardly notice any difference to the
bigger version
there's plenty of head and leg room
and the three door version has every bit
as much trunk space as the five-door
leone
the sc's interior is pleasantly
straightforward almost all the car's
functions can be operated with the touch
sensitive color display on the center
console
that cuts out many of the buttons and
leaves the cockpit looking tidy
the trapeze lines turn up again on the
vents and door handles
the instrument panel displays all the
key data front and center in the
driver's field of view
the overall harmonious concept
reinforces the car's personality and our
test driver noticed something else
he points out one detail that seatt is
especially proud of the quality
workmanship an example is that the crack
of the rubber door seals is narrower
than on its more expensive volkswagen
counterparts
but assist systems like the adaptive
high beam and lane assist with
drowsiness detection are only available
as options
einhold concludes that the sea leone sc
is not just a leaner version of its
five-door brother but a model in its own
right it handles well and boasts
excellent workmanship and it cuts a
handsome figure
the leon sc starts at 14 890 euros in
germany but the model we tested with the
second most powerful diesel and dsg
transmission would cost twenty five
thousand five hundred forty euros